hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome and wild bullet game uh between
magnus carlson and sergey shigalki was
played unleashes a few months ago and uh
jigalco is always around the the highest
rated or the second highest rated bullet
player on leeches currently he's at 3075
rating and the the second highest rated
uh and he played almost 35 000 bullet
games so he's extremely experienced and
extremely dangerous
and that this game is just completely
crazy if you've seen the thumbnail uh
it's hard to imagine something like this
even happening
over the course of uh one minute okay or
two minutes since it's one minute each
uh but that being said let's check out
the game we're not going to analyze it
deeply or anything since it's a bullet
game but we are going to cover the the
fun part so magnus with the white pieces
opens with not that with e4
we have c5 chicago goes for the sicilian
defense knight f3 knights the c6 and now
magnus goes for the close sicilian or
rather the old sicilian variation with
bishop to c4
knight to f6 so not striking in the
center we have d3 and defending on e4
and e6 now opening up the the dark
square bishop and now uh this position
has been reached before and there are a
couple of moves that were played here
but magnus just plays bishop to b3 and
in this particular position it is a new
move so already as of move five we have
a completely new game as you goku says
all right i don't know what that is but
i'm gonna play d5 because why not you
you've allowed it yeah magnus pushes e5
knight to d7 and now queen to e2 we need
to keep an eye on our pawn on e5 so
queen to c7 adding a third attacker and
magnus adds a third defender with bishop
to f4
and now you could continue with
something like b5 prepare c4 but jigalco
says all right let's just uh hone in on
that e5 pawn and play f6 but f6 is a
dangerous move in any position and it's
a dangerous move in this position
because here uh magnus just castle of
course this is a bullet game so we can't
uh find everything but there is this
sneaky bishop captures on d5 and uh you
cannot capture the bishop you have to
play uh something else and
what do you play here probably something
like knight to d4 then we trade knights
and then you know the bishop captures on
e6 but all in all white should be better
here if you capture the bishop then we
just pick up the queen that's it the
game over white wins uh but okay yeah it
would be complicated to go for this if
you don't have time to calculate so
magnus just castles here and now sergey
says thank you for the e5 pawn so knight
capture sun uh not that night knight d
captures on e5 we have knight captures
on e5f captures on e5 now having this
massive center here bishop to g3 by
magnus and adjust the bishop to d6
continuing development and preparing
castles we have c4 by magnus now going
after the d5 pawn and now knight the d4
attacking the queen and putting pressure
on the bishop here on b3 so queen back
to d1 by magnus and now h5 shigaoku not
interested in castling he wants to go
after the
the white king so magnus stops it with
h4 and now g5 the attack continues we
have knight to c3 putting more pressure
on this d5 pawn and now g captures on h4
it's important to open lines in front of
your opponent's king if you are to
attack so bishop captures an h4 and now
knight captures on b3 this is uh maybe
an unnecessary capture but like we said
it's a bullet game nothing is
unnecessary maybe just shifting the
queen over to the attack and then trying
something there is the way to go but
okay knight captures on b3 magnus plays
a captures on b3 if black is castling
anywhere it's on the queen side so we
might as well open our a file for the
rook queen to f7 now and rook to e1
aligning a rook with the king that's
still an e1 and even if you play bishop
to d7 you still can't castle our bishop
on h4 is uh making sure of that so maybe
uh this capture on h4 was a bit
premature maybe just you know getting
our king to safety and then continuing
but this is all what if
what if this was not a bullet game so
rook the g8 of course we're preparing to
attack the white king and now magnus
goes for the move and that is pawn to b4
so now we want to uh
we want to capture on c5 but also if
black captures on b4 we can just play
knight b5 put pressure on the bishop of
course the king and queen are here so
you have to be very careful and if
bishop moves back we're just gonna
capture on d5 and now it could get very
dangerous for this black king
but okay bishop to d7 was played so now
b captures on c5 attacking the bishop
bishop captures on c5 and now c captures
on d5 so busting open the position and
again it's very dangerous the bishop
here uh slicing over here the rook
controlling the e file and what do you
play here uh if you play something like
e captures on d5 then d4 is very
dangerous the bishop
can't really capture because we can
capture with the queen the e pawn is
pinned so white really just breaks
breaks through here so instead we have
bishop to d4 stopping the advancement of
white's d-pawn and now magnus just goes
knight to e4 you could also capture on
e6 but this also works now we are
threatening knight to d6
uh to win black's queen so queen to g6
makes sense we get the queen out of the
way and we're threatening checkmate so
how can magnus prevent this well knight
to f6 with check king to f7 and now
white is completely winning but you have
to be very precise here feel free to
pause the video and win this game for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding uh any of
the winning moves but the really truly
forcing one uh is just queen to f3 uh
you could also play d captures an e6
check first but queen to f3 is
sufficient this is what magnus played
and now there really isn't uh all that
much black can do here so
congratulations to everyone who found
this you are a true seeker of the of the
purest of moves uh and now what do you
do you're threatening to move the knight
somewhere and then open up a discovery
here the queen also defends against
checkmate so there's that uh so how can
black proceed here the problem is if you
just move the king to help defend the
bishop here we of course don't go after
the bishop we just checkmated the black
king 94 check from the bishop king moves
knight to d6 checkmate that's the good
stuff the bishop covers this diagonal
the queen covers f7f8
this is just checkmate so of course you
can do this after queen to f3 uh jigalco
tried something else he played e
captures on d5 he said all right have
your bishop i'm gonna you know continue
my attack there's really nothing i can
do about this so knight captures on d7
by magnus opening up a discovery king
the e6 and now knight captures an e5 so
again threatening very nasty discoveries
now with the rook and also the black
queen is under attack here so bishop
captures on e5 you have to play this and
now just uh d4 attacking the pinned
piece so the bishop cannot move we have
to play something rook ate the f8 was
played attacking carlsen's queen so
again if he moves it he's getting
checkmated here so here we have rook
captures on e5 with check i will just
mention because i often mention things
that are enjoyable rook the a6 check is
the quickest way for white to win but
we're only going to mention this uh you
know you can work out the rest uh but
here magnus played rook captures and if
i would check king to d7 now comes queen
captures on d5 with check king to c8 and
now queen to c5 with check making sure
that he can capture an a7 now he's very
glad he uh captured with uh with uh
the a pawn here opening up his a file
for the rook and if you go king to d7
you're just getting checkmated so
there's no point in playing this queen
to seven will be checkmate so he played
king to b8 but now queen captures on a7
with czech king c8 rook the c1 check
kink the d7 and now queen captures on b7
with check of course the rook controls
the e file king to d6 was played and now
pretty much any move you make here will
be checkmate uh like a queen to
queen to d5 will be checkmate queen to
c6 will be checkmate queen to c7 will be
checkmate queen to e7 will be checkmate
bishop to e7 will be checkmate uh but
magnus chooses to deliver mate with the
rook so he plays rook to c6 and it is
now checkmate on move 34.
uh so there we have it a very enjoyable
bullet game thank you for suggesting
such a such a brilliancy and you can see
how things can go really really wrong
and how much can happen over the course
of uh of a bullet game this is just
unreal uh because when these guys that
are like 3 000 and above rated uh uh you
know play play bullet uh their their
games are really really awesome uh and
uh well they they pretty much play much
better than we would having uh like an
hour
of time to the thing for for for a move
so it's really incredible what they can
achieve in such uh short periods of time
but yeah after rooks c6 of course this
is checkmate and magnus won a very nice
game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh let me know if you guys
also enjoy some bullet or maybe even
hyper bullet or maybe even shorter time
formats or are you just uh interested in
maybe longer blitz three plus so five
plus so and you know and above maybe
even just classical uh there are still
people that that only play classical and
that's uh that's really awesome uh so
yeah once again i hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank olga the
dinosaur david kimura ravindra yoga be
malta and pedro quila miranda for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the usgs championship
checking up any wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent start of your week